tu as pu passer plus de temps avec zahia
c'est le côté positif c'est cette année
c'est que j'ai passé du temps que je
n'aurais jamais pu passer en tandem avec
ton fils
c'est cesser c'est un bonheur absolu ah
ben tu connais ça a forcément ça ça m'a
changé la vie hein c'est on se réveille
plus pour les mêmes raisons le matin
quand on rentre le soir on est heureux
de rentrer on est pressé de rentrer et
puis et puis way cccc ohis on s'adonne à
une nouvelle un nouveau sens à la vie
quand on se réveille toi tu sais
pourquoi tu vois tout ce qui se passe
actuellement
tu habites amis tout en ce moment tout
marche et ça fait six mois que j'étais
là je vais repasser les fêtes aux états
unis il y avait un peu moitié-moitié
c'est ça est-ce que tu as peur du monde
qui arrive pour ton pour ton fils
ah c'est sûr que c'est en plus il est né
en 2001 je pense que dans l'année dans
l'ère moderne là c'est quand même une
année fera sera comme tu dis les manifs
de notre pays en france on a beaucoup
souffert déjà avant l'arrivée du coc
vide
maintenant voilà c'est c'est le but
c'est de les lever en lui faisant
prendre conscience que dans le monde il
ya ça qui va pas il ya des gens pour qui
c'est pas facile tous les jours il ya
toi tu vas peut-être et sûrement être un
privilégié parce que tes parents ont la
chance de faire un métier plutôt cool
maintenant
maintenant voilà ce mois le but c'est de
les lever comme moi j'ai été élevé
c'est-à-dire de de côtoyer tous tous
styles de gens tous styles 2000 et
dresse de respecter peu importe ce qu'on
fait dans la vie d'où on vient
et puis l'école du sport je pense à être
important aussi pour venus à quelque
chose j'ai envie qu'ils fassent du sport
juste pour savoir qu' il faut il faut
mériter sa place quand tu veux jouer le
week-end c'est pas volé la place du
copain s'est mérité la tienne c'est
toutes ces valeurs là que moi j'ai
apprise
en faisant du sport voilà je vais
l'élever dans ces valeurs là et l'ouvrir
au monde en la france etats unis voir
que des envies qui l'habite ou ferrand
l'envi qu'ils habitent dans les deux ans
à les deux mois c'est important pour le
bas déjà sa mère à voile à servir sur ma
belle famille est là à ma famille est
ici donc moi j'ai envie que qui est qui
qui se sentent autant français que
qu'américains